it's time for cookbook club digital
edition for those joining for the first
time cookbook club is our show's
collective cooking experience where we
post recipes in advance so everyone can
be prepared to cook along with us
joining me today is harvard grad and the
youngest finalist on masterchef oh and
just one of tick tock's top u.s food
creators with over 6 million followers
please welcome chef
nick digiovanni
thank you so much
thank you normally obviously we'd be
chatting at the cookbook of our choice
but
you brought us a very special recipe and
i want you to tell us why it's special
to you yeah absolutely it's right here
actually it's in this it's in this
wooden box so my my my grandmother was
probably the biggest person i took
cooking inspiration from so we found
this is this is so lucky that this is
happening today because we found this
literally i think last week but it's a
recipe box i've already taken one out so
we have all the the ingredients here to
make it's called scalloped scallops uh
which you know funnily enough i've never
tried i've never gotten to make so i'm
glad we found this and it basically
looks like scalloped potatoes but
scallop form
first of all can i see
i love scalloped anything right sort of
like fried
i think this box is the coolest thing
ever and it's literally what the soul of
what we're trying to do is all about
it's perfect they're all just
handwritten scrabbled on piece of paper
it's perfect yeah this is so cool yeah
well
you know obviously it's not a cookbook
club without another cookbook enthusiast
and we'd love to welcome colleen
hi
hi colleen how are you i'm so happy to
meet you i'm personally so excited to be
here and to meet nick and to meet you i
heard you're a huge master chef fan i am
a addict of all things cooking shows so
that's uh yeah that's my jam i really
enjoy that and masterchef i have such
respect for them because they are
working these are home cooks these are
not
formally trained how they work under
that kind of pressure i don't know i
don't know what's it like working under
gordon ramsay may i ask it's intense
that's the first question anybody asked
too
i it's i thought it was awesome i i love
i really love pressure not just because
in college it makes you write the paper
the night before it's due right but just
because i don't know i think in the
kitchen pressure and heat and kind of
running around and all that that's what
it's all about yeah i love it all right
should we get going we should totally
get going nick you're driving let's do
this and we are your humble students yes
okay you ready yes okay first we got we
got two different types of bread crumbs
here so we have ritz and we have panko
super buttery and delicious so why not
use them here right so
now it's being buttery we have more
butter that we're going to put into the
bread crumbs okay
so i'm going to blah
right i'm going to go ahead and just
whole thing the whole thing don't hold
back buttercup
you should definitely post more on tick
tock
really yeah you know i haven't gone on
it yet i'm just a giant avid fan but um
you're not on i know what
colleen are you on tick tock uh yeah
well
pauline our lives are paralleling a lot
because i heard that like
at 60 you're basically like i'm ready
for health wellness crossfit everything
and at 46 i'm ready to get my act
together too yes yes well my 50s kind of
sucked so um i want my 60s to be i want
to go into my 60s healthy
and
strong and so that's that's my that's my
goal for this year 35 to 45 was real
doozy for me too i was like
but it was the decade that taught me the
most in my life lessons right absolutely
um well you're going to need crossfit
after this so
i am so excited okay back to you nick
we've buttered our crumbs we buttered
our crumbs now we're going to place a
layer at the bottom of our cute little
trays here of just those crumbs and
butter
just put a nice layer just trying to eat
the crumbs i know right
smells delicious colleen do you like
scallops i love scallops there's not
much i don't like i know i'm with you
too
i sort of have it is that no that looks
great we just yeah just a little bit
because we're actually gonna do we're
actually gonna do three total layers of
the crub so try to keep a couple we'll
we'll figure it out it's it's a free
french it's a free-for-all now we're
gonna go with our scallops so i'm just
gonna layer those these scallops are cut
in half so it makes it easier to kind of
layer them and get a couple back and
forth layers of it it's like building a
cake here do you cut it in half so that
it cooks better or is it just because
that way it layers more delicately i
think it's to layer more delicately just
sort of just like when you would make
scalloped potatoes
theoretically i'd love to try this
recipe as well just cutting them even
thinner at some point too just to see
what the differences are so we got our
layer right everyone's got their layer
of scallops then a little bit of salt
and pepper we got to just
doctor those up a little bit and don't
be shy nick is it true what all chefs
say that the difference between a
professional chef or restaurant quality
food and the humble home cook is the
seasoning i think so i think seasoning
but but also
perhaps equally important if not more
important sometimes is the temperature
for me when you get something super hot
or super cold if it's supposed to be
that way i'm actually writing a cookbook
um right now it's it's going to come out
this november with my culinary partner
and client paular valdez and
i wrote a story in there called serve
hot oh because her and i had an incident
where we were
making a very important meal for very
important people and i messed the whole
thing up and she had to serve the food
cold and
it was a moment it happens
another layer of bread crumbs now though
ritz
so make sure you leave enough for the
very top okay just to try to you know
keep keep it keep them all protected in
there and then another layer of scallops
and we can also we have a little bit of
cream because of course scalloped
anything has a bunch of cream in it so
you can go with your layer of cream
right now if you want a little bit of it
i'm going to go with the layer do it do
it how you want right no
dude you're both jumping right for the
cream i'm gonna go for it too well it's
cream yeah it's cream it's delicious
oh yeah a little bit of cream in there
oh gosh that's awesome
oh gosh this is just beautiful ah
and then on your mouth more scallops so
nick
i understand that you actually launched
a product literally today
yeah isn't that crazy i i'm so excited
because we get to
promote it and announce it i know i what
are the odds too it's pretty pretty
awesome it's it's um
i wouldn't call it the name nerdy but
it's osmo which comes from osmosis when
you add salt to anything right
um
and and there's there's a bunch of
different flavors i have that i actually
have the roasted garlic one here that's
delicious um but i've been working on
these for a long time and we just
happened to launch them today so it's a
seasoned mix it's just it's just salt
they're just flavored salts really
really fun yeah salt is love i know salt
is so important right so many different
kinds of salt
and i am so excited to try your new
product it's really it's really really
tasty this one literally is like if you
took roasted garlic out of the oven and
then just
combined it with salt right it's
delicious all right you want to try it
oh go for it oh
beautiful packaging yeah isn't that fun
buddy yeah
nick congratulations pretty right it's a
boy
[Applause]
how can you tell
this is really cool yeah and really
beautiful packaging thank you so much
yeah i'm really excited i'm really
excited colleen what
made you a cookbook lover and a culinary
watcher my favorite thing to do is like
sit on the couch and eat food while i
watch food shows
yes yes yes everything well you know
it's because i love to eat and i love to
cook and uh
cooking shows i i mean i've watched
every single one of them and that's
where i learned and you know i i lost my
son in 2010 and cooking became my
therapy so i start i took a an online
cooking course and i'm just obsessed i'm
just obsessed colleen i'm so sorry to
hear about your son
and i understand that the summer camp he
went to changed their name to honor him
and now your daughter is a counselor i
know right i know it's very special and
the fact that my daughter is now the
director
is just full circle so it's really
really something
you're amazing oh thank you
and and cooking is my therapy and it's
my love so
yeah
that is amazing it really is
it really is
thank you i'm so glad you shared that
story with us by the way i was i was
peeking over at both of your both of
your scallop scallops they look a lot i
don't know what happened to mine that
they're
lacking coverage they're lacking
coverage but it's fine um i'm just glad
that you're proud of what we're doing
because
i usually mess up in the kitchen and
that's part of the charm
but i'm i'm not feeling too bad about
that i got too excited about more cream
and the bread crumbs
this is ready it's super simple to
prepare i'm good
it's very homey and cozy and you're
right it is really simple and then we
toss this in the oven at 350 for 25
minutes that's it and then just hit it
with a few greens on the top to make it
look pretty at the end and that's it
this is our finished product over here
okay nice and warm is it rude to just go
straight in i think so i think this is a
single serving
we do single serving colleen you are a
woman after my part i've gone great
we have plates and they also have a a
salad out of the the same recipe box
it's a shaved apple and fennel salad and
then i actually also have some toasted
pine nuts
because this was my favorite thing that
my grandmother taught me was toast pine
nuts so i put them on
every salad i eat really yeah i love um
toasted pumpkin seeds
yes they're delicious yep those give a
great yeah flavor and texture yep cheers
colleen cheers to you
cheers
this has been really good read a bowl
all right i have to try the salad now oh
my gosh nick what's in the sandwich
what's what's on top
it's apple and fennel you said yeah
shaved apple and fennel super simple
salad with a little shallot vinaigrette
it's like if it's amazing butter
bedding
mashed potatoes clouds
had a baby
and the scallops melt in your mouth
they're just they're just so tender and
yeah 20 minutes at fantastic 350 yeah 25
minutes at 350.
everyone's oven is different so
are these scallops cooked to your liking
because they really like are just
incredibly different beautiful
i i really like having the scallops it
makes a big difference
that is delicious thank you nick
digiovanni and colleen
thank you so much and go to the
drewberrymore show.com for the full
recipe
trust me it is heaven in your mouth
[Music]